well someone news moving in you might as
well redecorate I do try and put more
stuff that isn't Doctor Who related
between my Doctor Who videos so that I'm
not ever exclusively a Doctor Who
channel much as that is my most viewed
stuff but I'm not gonna put off talking
about this so word has come out with
some of the changes beyond the ones we
already know about ie
a new showrunner and new lead actor
playing the doctor in Doctor Who so he
there are a few other things that has
been confirmed that interior of the
TARDIS getting a full redesign Jodie
Whittaker is gonna be getting a whole
new sonic screwdriver neither of these
are huge surprises but I'll kind of come
back to them anyway the big thing we're
getting a format change and it's not a
massive change but in my mind it is a
significant one so previously knew who
modern era Doctor Who beginning with
series one with the ninth doctor
Christopher Eccleston back in 2005 that
has always had a 13 episode 40 to 45
minute long format now some have all
been self contained stories some series
have had more two parters so they've
experimented with that but the length of
individual episodes and the number of
episodes in a series has been pretty
much locked in since dr. who came back
well now we are going to be getting ten
episodes an hour long no word that I
could find saying whether they are
planning to do two parters if they are
how frequently they will but this just
so I can't speculate on that part of it
but we are getting fewer but longer
episodes and for me I consider this to
be a good thing because it is a change
to the format but it's not an overhaul
of the format it's not like trying to go
back to the serialized version that
classic who did not that I wouldn't
necessarily think that would be a bad
idea but that's that would be a pretty
drastic shift from from what we're doing
and I've seen some people float the idea
of doing you know more continuous
storylines and I have mixed feelings
about that but I
not gonna talk about that I'll talk
about the information we have here's why
it's a particularly good idea it combats
what and I'm gonna quote another
youtuber here Stu bagful has termed
45-minutes syndrome which is that there
are a fair number of stories that you
can tell have had either subplots
truncated or stuff that's happening just
faster than it should then it's
happening because there's too much going
on for something that is only slotted
for 45 minutes and if we could get 15
extra minutes we could get maybe a
little bit more time with the supporting
cast and get you know the guest stars
for any given episode maybe we can
explore the b-line because some the the
best of Doctor Who episodes balance all
this really well but some have a really
difficult time either giving proper
acknowledgement of the doctor and the
companions and what they're going
through as well as giving us a
compelling story that they have happened
to stumble in on oftentimes one is kind
of sacrificed on the altar of the other
again there are plenty of episodes that
balance those but when you have only 45
minutes it is it is not difficult to
basically make the decision okay
something's just not gonna get its
proper due in this episode and I think
going with a slightly longer episode
length is going to be a potentially a
good way to combat that and we can maybe
get some slightly deeper slightly richer
stories without having to actually
resort to making everything to parties
because they did try that with Capaldi
second series was series name we had a
lot of two-parters in there and
unfortunately we had the odd thing where
there were a couple of them that didn't
really feel like they should have been
two parters there were there were some
that were but there were others like the
girl who died in the woman who lived
that felt like completely different
stories just arbitrarily connected
together by one character to make it a
two-parter of sorts so that that you
know again that series wasn't bad but
sort of that using a lot more
two-parters to try and flush stuff out
was maybe a little too much because not
every story actually needs effectively
an hour and a half to tell but there
plenty of stories that could benefit
from just an extra 15 minutes so this is
a move that well it saddens me that I'm
going to get fewer Doctor Who episodes
in a series and that bums me out a
little bit this is an exciting change to
me and it's not guaranteed it's gonna
work getting any change that is made
could go for the better it could go for
the worse but I can see where this is
the potential to give us something a
little bit different that should not
really inherently impact the nature of
Doctor Who and how the stories function
but it could just give them a chance to
be a little richer a little deeper and
that's exciting to me I know I said I
was gonna come back to the interior
TARDIS sonic screwdriver
those aren't huge surprises both of
those got a drastic redesign when we had
the last showrunner changeover when
Steven Moffat came in we had a new
doctor new Cobain completely redesigned
interior TARDIS brand new sonic
screwdriver so bringing Chris Chibnall
in and it's not a huge surprise that
he's gonna do all these other things the
one part of me that's going a little bit
is just because and this is not a reason
not to change these things I think it
would be weirder to actually keep the
old stuff but I I can't help up on the
fact that peep that these changes to the
interior of the TARDIS to the sonic
screwdriver are gonna get scrutinized
way more than would normally happen
because of the already significant
changes that have already been made to
the show of course the big one being
Jodie Whittaker is the doctor now and
and I'm not even just talking about
people who are like not my doctor will
not watch I mean they weren't gonna tune
in anyway or at least they claimed they
weren't we'll see but there I think
there are other people who for whatever
reason and some of them young you know
change is scary there are many reasons
that people are skeptical about either
Chris Chibnall or Jodie Whittaker or
both and unfortunately I think that's
gonna because Jodie Whittaker her
casting has been such a shake-up and has
had some pretty significant
reverberations throughout the fandom
that it's going to just
have such a higher degree of scrutiny on
everything else that gets changed in
addition to that and that I just think
is unfortunate
I'll have opinions on when I actually
see the things um you know I'm whether I
think it's good or bad or whatever then
same thing with the doctor's outfit
which I said previously I think is gonna
be a much better indicator of how Jodie
Whittaker is gonna play the part than
just her being cast is I think once we
get our first look at Jodie in whatever
costume she's actually going to be
performing in with however the sonic
screwdriver is actually designed in an
actual look inside the TARDIS those
three things could actually start to
give us a pretty significant picture in
terms of how she's going to be
portraying that the role of the doctor
but as I said because people are sort of
a lot of fans are already on high alert
because she's just there all this
stuff's gonna get picked apart I think a
lot more than would otherwise happened
because like if I'm being honest the the
12th doctor sonic screwdriver I I have
it as a toy and it's probably my
favorite one in terms of having it as a
toy but design wise I think this is the
worst one that they've made so far and I
don't remember a whole - I got on too
many people who disagree with me but I
also don't remember a ton of outcry over
this thing however I feel like anything
about the new sonic screwdriver just
because it's gonna be Jody sonic
screwdriver there's gonna be a lot of
people who are just gonna be putting a
much more critical eye on it possibly
even subconsciously but I have a feeling
that if like if a design is sort of
weird and like possibly overly colorful
and just toy like as this gets put in
the hands of Jodie Whittaker there's
just gonna be a lot more outcry than the
fact that we had 12 doctor running
around with this thing and I love having
this but this thing is ridiculous but
we'll see what happens so what are your
thoughts on the latest round of updates
that we've got before what's gonna
change the format change let's focus on
that because like I said all we know
about the other things is that they are
changing there is a really
to say about that so what are your
thoughts on the format change good bad
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast available on the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
comm and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]